welcome back to sunday night in america
tensions are sky high between russia and
the west economic sanctions travel bans
business boycotts
have further isolated moscow from the
rest of the world putin is looking for
allies and may turn to cuba
russia claims it invaded ukraine in part
because it did not want weapons from the
west pointed at russia the u.s is not
likely to allow missiles pointed at our
country either and cuba is just 90 miles
from america what
should and will our response be
if russia and cuba partner up again
florida congresswoman maria salazar is
the daughter of cuban refugees and sits
on the house foreign affairs committee
she joins us now congresswoman what do
we know about the relationship between
russia and cuba
i think it's a fantastic question and
it's very timely well cuba and russia
are enjoying right now the warmest
relationship that they have had since
the fall of the soviet union
last month vladimir putin sent his
deputy to go to havana and they
negotiated with the castro's two things
number one to uh light up again this a
spy post called ludus where the russians
can intercept every military
communication that we have because
remember that havana is 90 miles away
from miami the city that i represent in
congress and not only that the russians
are now willing to pay the cubans to fix
and revamp their airports their ports
and use them obviously for military
purposes down the line so while um trey
while russia is doing this despicable
act
against the ukrainians they have been
penetrating cuba since the last couple
of years and it's paying off because
cuba venezuela and nicaragua are with
vladimir putin in this war but it's not
only cuba it's venezuela which is even
worse i'm not sure if you know that this
weekend juan gonzalez who is the
national security council advisor
is in caracas negotiating with nicolas
maduro because the biden administration
has come up with the idea since we're
going to probably shut off oil from
russia now we're going to buy it from
the venezuelans so so so we are
punishing one tyrant in order to benefit
another but you know why what's really
under what's really underpinning all the
situation is the fact that the marxists
are part of the democratic party and
they are not allowing biden to do what
is morally correct from this country
which is to help people that want to be
free
all right speaking of freedom what can
the u.s do with respect to cuba to fan
the flame of freedom in that country
what can and should we be doing to
incent the cuban people who want to be
free
oh
thank you there's one thing that the
biden administration could do which is
to empower the cuban people to come out
on the streets again and shout what
everything they want to which is the
same thing they did in july 11th of last
year
people cubans want to be free and we
need to give them one thing leadership
and connectivity i i myself have spoken
with the state department many times
asking them please give the cubans the
same thing that we're trying to give the
ukrainians connectivity internet because
once the cuban regime turns off the
internet
like they did with the ukrainians the
cubans will know those who are on the
street being brutalized by the
repressive apparatus they will know that
at least the rest of the world is
watching what they want to do that's the
first thing connectivity and number two
sending the message to raul castro that
we are now we the united states we're
not going to allow military personnel
we're not going to allow for the
russians to be paying for anything in
cuba and that we want to make sure that
putin
doesn't have an ally in the casters but
we're not doing that with venezuela with
nicaragua and with cuba
all right congresswoman you're in the
minority in the house at least for now
is there any sense that the democrats in
the house and they run the show are
putting pressure on biden to get tougher
on
russia whether it's in ukraine or
whether it's in cuba is
is there pressure coming from the house
democrats because that's who he listens
to
no be unfortunately because as you know
there is a a part of the democratic
party that believes that this country is
bad and that marxism is the right
ideology
and unfortunately i always tell my
colleagues that they have drank the
kool-aid that they do not what
democratic socialism means anything that
has to do with socialism if not ask of
the ukrainians my friend victoria spark
who is the only ukrainian on the floor
we know we cubans my parents my
ancestors so that is why the biden
administration has not been able to be
more forceful against vladimir putin
against the casters or against the
maduro regime i'm telling you one of his
advisors is right now in caracas
negotiating so may the lord help this
country but we know that that influence
that biden is surrounded by is nefarious
for the future of america
well thank you congresswoman for keeping
your eye on all the different spots
south america cuba ukraine can't wait to
have you back on thank you for joining
us on the sunday night hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else